auch ein thema zum zudem corona würmer
man blickt nicht mehr durch es ist ein
drei wochen her am 11 oktober da wurde
die kostenfreiheit für den schnelltest
aufgehoben das argument war wir wollen
die sie nicht haben kämpfen lassen wann
ein bisschen dahin drängen dass sie doch
eine sich eine impfung beim zukommen
lassen der schnelltest wurde
kostenpflichtig er kostet etwa 14 90
euro das ist eine ganze menge wenn man
zu viert ein restaurantbesuch zum
beispiel
ein paar wochen später und das war vor
wenigen tagen hat sich die regierung in
berlin aber auch in anderen
bundesländern wir haben es gerade von
einem ronzheimer gehört von sachsen dazu
entschieden dass sie zweig einführen
zweig heißt nur geimpfte und genießen
dürfen noch zb ein restaurant versuchen
über eine veranstaltung in berlin
spricht man auch über 2g plus und auch
in anderen bundesländern was heißt das
2g plus bedeutet dass sich auch die
geimpften festen lassen müssen das wird
in berlin zum beispiel am kommenden
dienstag beschlossen das heißt also der
test ist nun kostenpflichtig den
geimpften wurde erzählt die würde die
freiheiten zurückbekommen die man
angenommen hatte mit dem corona
verordnungen diese freiheit wird ihn nun
wieder genommen in dem auch sie einen
test vorlegen müssen obwohl sie geimpft
sind den müssen sie bezahlen was was
soll ich damit anfangen natürlich muss
jetzt der test sofort wieder kostenfrei
gemacht werden darüber wird aber nicht
gesprochen schauen wir mal nach dänemark
denn er mag hat nicht nur die em-krone
verordnungen weitgehend aufgehoben sogar
die masten sicht nein denn immer gibt es
im kostenlosen schnell testen sogar eher
pcr test ist kostenlos im ganzen land an
jeder ecke was ist das ergebnis die
leute lassen sich stark testen also kann
man auch die infektionsketten besser
nachverfolgen wieder einmal hat es nicht
funktioniert wieder einmal läuft es
gegeneinander wir werden nicht schlau
draus die regeln passen nicht zusammen
man hat vergessen dass der test nicht
mehr kostenfrei ist man führt ihn jetzt
ein für geimpfte wie soll es weitergehen
ich weiß es nicht ich blicke nicht mehr
durchblickt jemand durch am tisch
also ich kann für mich auch nicht
behaupten dass ich noch durchblick das
ist das große problem glaube ich leute
wie wir die sich so viel mit dem thema
beschäftigen und dann auch nicht sagen
können was jetzt in welchem bundesland
genau gilt sie haben gerade schon
darüber gesprochen herr kretschmann
heute angekündigt zweig in sachsen kommt
flächendeckend und setzt sich damit ja
schon ab von anderen bundesländern ich
glaube das ist auch ein großes problem
was wir auch seit beginn der pandemie
erleben sondern bisschen auch das
wettrennen zwischen den bundesländern
natürlich sind einzelnen länder stärker
betroffen als andere natürlich kann man
denn in einigen ländern vielleicht
härtere maßnahmen erklären als in
anderen aber dennoch hat man das gefühl
dass das nicht politik aus einem guss
ist und jetzt kommen wir in ein
besonderes problem dass wir in einer
koalitions sondierungsphase in einer
verhandlungsphase sind momentan und dass
die sehr wahrscheinliche neue regierung
noch nicht wirklich etwas zu sagen hat
und die alte nur noch geschäftsführend
im amt ist und das bedeutet glaube ich
am ende dass wir ein hin und her erleben
dass wir auch bei den parteien ein hin
und her erleben jetzt hat christian
lindner der finanzminister werden will
heute in bild gesagt dass genau das
passieren muss die schnelltests eben
kostenlos werden aber er kann ja noch
gar nicht sagen dazu so richtig war noch
nicht im amt ist also ich glaube wir
erleben hier auch durch die
koalitions phase ein chaos und keine
wirklich richtige corona politik und am
ende finde ich erleben wir auch
politiker die sich die das gewohnt waren
dass sie jeden tag in der tagesschau bei
uns bei bild überall zu sehen waren
unter anderem helge braun ja die wollen
sie auf den letzten metern jetzt noch
mal profilieren weil danach würde
niemand mehr was von ihnen wissen dann
sind sie nicht mein regierungsämtern
dann sind sie nicht mehr im kanzleramt
und dann ist schluss also jetzt noch mal
jeden tag eine neue forderung und man
muss ich da auch mal fragen ob die ganze
hysterie die plötzlich ausgebrochen es
vor wenigen tagen ob sie gerechtfertigt
ist wir haben im sommer zur kenntnis
genommen dass die instanz zahl gar
keinen wert ist der von großer bedeutung
sei denn sie bezieht ja alle
altersgruppen mit ein also wenn kinder
und jugendliche infiziert sind heißt das
noch lange nicht dass sie schwer
erkranken und so weiter und so fort ich
will das jetzt nicht noch mal ausführen
die meisten jetzt hier zuschauen wissen
ist auch warum aber ist die instanz zahl
dann jetzt wieder der panik faktor warum
und wo sind die zahlen also zum beispiel
zu den zu der belegung der
intensivbetten warum haben wir eine
eilmeldung aus bayern aus dem kreis
miesbach dort sogar die drei geht die
drei g + ich freue mich ganz mit die 3g
plus einzuführen das heißt das erklären
sie mache
ich mir heute noch schnell an gelesen
dann würde ich gut vorbereitet in die
sendung kommen das ist eine erfindung
aus bayern süd ich weiß nicht ob es
jetzt aus münchen kommt 3g plus heißt
also genesene geimpfte und getestete
gehen dürfen ins restaurant gehen oder
hat es ins konzert aber es muss einen
pcr-test er kostet was man sagt sondern
17 bester ab so das geht doch nicht was
wollen 91 13 von 15 und da und das komme
ich auf das zurück was sie gesagt haben
ja das ist doch so zu sagen was heißt
der impfzwang durch die hintertür das
ist der impfzwang also wenn ich mir das
leben gar nicht mehr leisten kann wenn
nicht dann haben sie da haben sie ja das
ist perfide und erhöhte glaube ich dass
sich die menschen auch daran halten
werden dass man gerade passieren also
auch in sachsen muss man ja sagen gibt
in eine eine große zahl von menschen die
den corona maßnahme sehr kritisch
gegenüberstehen die sich auch nicht
impfen lassen wollen und jetzt greift er
ministerpräsident da so durch glaubst du
das ist da auch neue form von protesten
geben kann ja eigentlich abgeebbt waren
bei den querdenker man hat das gefühl
die haben sich so ein bisschen richtung
telegramm gruppen und so weiter
verschoben aber
mutter wieder was ja ich glaube es wird
für eine spaltung der gesellschaft oder
also das haben wir ja gar nicht spalten
es ist schon eine da das hat man ja an
dem fall chemisch gesehen ein mann der
eigentlich nur darauf hinweist dass er
sich nicht impfen lässt aber sie wurden
verurteilt der das macht weder durch die
medien getrieben worden ist also ich
kann konnte das überhaupt nicht
verstehen und natürlich also das trägt
über die maßnahmen werden desto mehr
mängel werden sich der
protest wird es aus dem blinker linken
lager geben die dann jede kritik wie es
auch schon bei kim ich mich war als
textil das können wir immer sagen
wir finden das alles quatsch was dann
passiert ja wir haben da muss man ja
sagen als journalistin die schöne
aufgabe immer kritisch darauf zu schauen
und können sie war so ungefähr sagt wie
die lösung aussehen sollte aber so
richtig konkret müssen wir es nicht
machen alexander kissler
kann man denn bei den zahlen die wir
jetzt erleben und nehmen wir mal an oder
glauben wir mal dass das stimmt was
programm losert dass die intensivbetten
belegung wieder hochgeht und man kann ja
an den zahlen sehen dass es vergleichbar
ist eigentlich mit dem letzten jahr was
wäre aus ihrer sicht was wären da die
richtigen maßnahmen zunächst einmal
glaube ich selbstverständlich die
berichte dass intensivstation gibt die
überfüllt sind das glaube ich sofort man
weiß nicht genau ist es dann im
durchbrüche zu welchen teil zehn bis 40
prozent 0 prozent es gibt neben der
pandemie der ungeimpften auch einen
pandemie der geimpften das wissen wir
dass sagte kekule immer wir haben beides
wir sollten uns nicht kapieren das eine
gegen das andere auszuspielen
der weg aus der pandemie hieß es immer
ist impfen jetzt hören wir auf einmal
booster impfung ist der weg aus der
pandemie ich würde sagen testen ist der
weg aus dem weg das frappant wir müssen
uns testen aus der pandemie
herauszubekommen und zwar alle und was
ich ebenso landes vätern auch die hunde
geimpft sind würde ich sagen ja und ganz
sicher zu sein kostenlose tests für
jeden geimpft oder nicht geimpft und was
ich eben landes vätern wie ramelow und
kretschmer vorwerfe kretschmann auch ja
sie haben eine schwierige lage vor ort
aber sie gehen neben sehenden auges in
kauf dass eine wachsende gruppe der
bevölkerung sich vom start ab wendet
wenn das lied band einmal gebrochen des
vertrauens band zwischen bürger und
regierenden dann kann man das auch auf
anderen feldern nicht mehr heilen und
das sehe ich die gefahr damit der
spieler der hg aber
ich glaube dass grundsatz hier man muss
die menschen mitnehmen und wir haben
hier teilweise politiker sie versuchen
durch diese angst so profitieren hier
bild irgendwie auch in der
öffentlichkeit zu schaffen machen sie
dann war da zum beispiel zum beispiel
auch aber nicht nur also auch was ramlow
hier sagt und andere es gibt keine
strategie es gibt vor allem nicht diese
welle die menschen mitzunehmen und sie
sagen uns bürger und bürgern was wir zu
tun haben und welche einstellungen wie
haben aber die regierung kann auch was
tun und ich meine wenn wir diese dritte
impfung haben sollen wo sind bitteschön
die die gerade auf machen sollen da
suchen sie beim arzt anzurufen einen
termin zu kriegen das ist fast unmöglich
da mussten wir ganz ganz lange warten
und diese aufgabe kein grund die praxen
alleine auch nicht alles gutes thema
gunnar schupelius in den usa zum
beispiel ist es so wenn man da das war
auch schon beim impfen letzten booster
schott haben würde da geht man einfach
einladen dann bekommt man den sätzlich
fünf minuten hin und ist wieder draußen
und wir haben das ja auch bei der ersten
punkte hinbekommen dass das irgendwie
unbürokratisch gehandelt wurde wieso
kriegen länder wie die usa oder auch
israel denn das beim boosten ja viel
viel früher erkannt haben dass so viel
besser an als wir dann weiß ich nicht
kann ich nicht sagen der antwortet er
ich kann es leider kann es nur zur
kenntnis nehmen inzwischen ist etwas
besser geworden glaube ich dass man die
impfung doch ein bisschen schneller
kriegt als als in den anfangsjahren
also das ist jetzt mein eindruck im
moment aber um noch mal auf die zahlen
zurückzukommen ich bezweifle dass
grundsätzlich das was jetzt alles gesagt
wird weil
jetzt ganz ganz einfach wir haben ich
erinnere mich genau am dreißigsten april
20 21 gab der gesundheitsminister des
bundes bekannt dass keine einzige
station irgend eines krankenhauses in
deutschland jemals während der pandemie
überlastet war das hatte eine ein
gremium festgestellt dass er bestellt
hatte 30 april 20 21 das wurde nach ist
nach
danach festgestellt
die begründung für den locker und war
aber immer die überlastung der
intensivstation die drohende oder
bereits eingetreten überlastung
hinterher erfahren wir dass keine
einzige station wirklich überlastet war
was soll ich damit anfangen wenn sie
jetzt wieder sagen sie seien alle
überlastet wieso soll ich das glauben
also ganz einfach nur der fakt ist doch
schon dass wir momentan vier bis
fünftausend weniger intensiv betten zur
verfügung haben als vor einem jahr nicht
weil uns die technik fehlt sondern weil
uns das personal fehlt weil die menschen
überlassen sagen für das wenige geld tue
ich mir nicht noch mal die dritte vierte
fünfte welle an und das ist auch
wiederum die frage an eine regierung die
sich parteiübergreifend
nachhaltigkeit auf die fahnen
geschrieben hat ja dann meist dann
versagt das irre sich ich würde sagen
das feld zunächst mal in die länder und
die länder muss ich sagen hätten dort
also pflege offensive an anleihen müssen
es gibt auch viele kommunale kommunale
krankenhäuser auch dort gab es keine
hinreichenden gehaltserhöhungen man kann
nicht sagen was er völlig stimmt das
gesundheitssystem ist ein kernbereich
zur stabilisierung unserer infrastruktur
unseres gesellschaftlichen systems und
dann sagen wir lassen es einfach so
laufen wie bisher ja wir lassen sogar
sehen den augen es noch schlechter
werden und warum warum haben wir nichts
daraus gelernt das ist ja dann fast uns
alle umtreibt eigentlich dass es ging
doch schon im letzten herbst als der lok
down zwar am zweiten november fängt
wurde haben gesagt was haben sie
eigentlich den ganzen sommer über getan
jetzt sind wir im zweiten pandemie
herbst aber sie können die leute noch
nicht zwingend wenn grundsätzlich zu
beantworten warum legt der staat die
verantwortung nicht in die hände der
menschen zurück also das haben wir ja
wir haben doch beispiele jetzt aus
dänemark und england warum schauen wir
nicht da drauf also der freedom day hat
sich bisher nicht so ausgewirkt dass die
lage da schlimmer ist als bei uns so
viel kann ich feststellen bessert wie
erlebst du
was die politikerinnen und politiker
jetzt versuchen man hat das gefühl die
versprechen werden langsam gebrochen es
gab also darüber zwei gesprochen über
einschränken und jetzt hat der erste
ministerpräsident
gesagt herr kretschmann dass es auch ein
lockdown für geimpfte geben könnte also
genau das was wir vor einem jahr erlebt
haben hältst du das ermöglicht dass das
passiert ich weiß es nicht also ich bin
massiv editiert von der kommunalpolitik
und zwar schon seit anfang der pandemie
also ich meine wie du schon gesagt hast
versprechen wurden gebrochen was war das
jetzt mit der booster impfung am anfang
gab es gar keine impfung also ich weiß
nicht es ist einfach nur ein absolutes
chaos ich habe auch muss ich zugeben
teilweise überhaupt sich bei den
überblick mehr wann wer etwas gesagt hat
und wann genau das wieder vorgezogen
worden ist also
nicht einfach nur ja mehrheit gezählt
sozusagen eines beta tester dass wir in
der korona pandemien da geht es ja
wirklich in vielen fällen um leben und
tod sehen was wir auch in vielen anderen
bereichen sehen nicht nur in berlin die
dysfunktionalität diese stars als dieser
staat funktioniert an vielen stellen
einfach nicht der br heute musste hier
bot er seinen betrieb einstellen weil
auf einer toilette ist ein rauchmelder
angeschlagen ist also dort ist es nicht
nur in berlin so dass wir einfach das
peter prinzip regeln lassen haben das
heißt man wird so lange aus befördert
bis man die höchste stufe seiner
inkompetenz erreicht hat und wenn es
dann gut läuft mein minister oder sogar
noch höher und das ist wirklich ein
problem und diese durch funktionalität
sind wir wieder ein brennglas in der
unfähigkeit die pandemie zu behandeln